this is a production of cornell
university
um thanks everyone thanks for the
introduction uh just to know i am part
of the
buckler and robin's labs uh co-mentored
um so yeah today i'm going to talk about
a cassava practical haplotype graph
for efficient amputation and hepatitis
crop
all right okay sorry um so first i want
to talk about andrew's kind of what is a
practical
type graph uh it's a tool for amputation
to help capture genomic variants across
the genome with minimal sequence input
so that's kind of the purpose of it and
why would we impute
uh there's a lot of different reasons to
but some of the main ones in breeding we
think about
are kind of allowing data from different
genotypic sources to be used together
and also to kind of capture more whole
genome variants for
maybe leverage other additional uh
annotations
um so just a basic kind of layout of
what making a phd looks like
basically take some whole genome
sequence um sometimes in
assemblies extract haplotypes and
populate a database
then we take to kind of test it we take
some low coverage genotyping
pass it through the alignment of the
database and get out
basically all the haplotypes
so how does it work um
well first we break up the genome into
these haplotype ranges we call reference
ranges
uh we then populate the database with
haplotypes from some parental germplasm
or
diversity panel um and then we make a
trellis graph this
is a graph structure that kind of
captures the relationship between
adjacent haplotypes and um
now we have this because genome um
we can take maybe an un genotype taxa
get some reads for it
align it to the band genome what this is
gonna
then we're gonna use a hidden markov
model
to find the most likely path through the
database
which then gives us our haplotype for
that new tax cell
uh but it's not just that simple because
working in a heterozygous crop like
cassava
you have to model two copies of the
genome so instead we you know we line
the reeds but they hit multiple places
and we then get the two most likely
paths uh representing the two copies of
the genome
so first i just want to introduce kind
of what this looks like in simulation
simulations can help us kind of test our
methodology
look see what things look like under
ideal conditions
um and so the simulation i'm going to
show here basically take
20 parents these are cassava real self
self-clones
simulate five generations of random
mating and then i my test amputation in
100 offspring and so just a test
invitation
would sample the offspring at low
coverage
use the phd to impute the missing
genotypes
determine accuracy by comparing it to
the true which we know because the
simulation
and then compare also uh how it does
with invitation to beagle which is very
common imputation
uh software that people use um
so this is what it looks like at least
for the simulation
we see the ph g in red i can't see my
mouse but um
you know the ph g in red outperforms
beagle in the simulated scenario across
many the x-axis is depth of coverage for
sequencing
so um but so and this this big gap
between them especially the lower
coverages
that's really due to the fact that the
beagle can't really distinguish between
heterozygous and homozygous calls
with that little of data so just because
if you see something once you don't know
if that's homozygous
maybe it's uh maybe you're not capturing
the second allele
um so now i've shown this really should
work
it does work in simulation um
even with two copies of the genome being
modeled um
the question is where do we get the
haplotypes for
for real data um because it's not quite
as simple as
as it may look so what i'm going to
showing you some of the data i'm using
from the hapmap 2
population created or kind of
consolidated a few years ago
by remo and the and the bucker lab
it's got 241 clones mainly from some
cultivated varieties but
our columns but also for there's some
wild uh
lines in there as well so how do we find
haplotypes well one of the problem
challenges i'm going to
talk about is getting phased haplotypes
is not as easy as it sounds
from whole genome sequence uh just
imagine these three sites
uh two of which are segregating we've
got heterozygous at
sites one and three oh so you're like
okay we've got the genotype
but that is not a haplotype um we don't
know
if the genome looks like this with two
haplotypes acg and cct
or act and ccg
and so even with two snips or two
celerying sites this can be harder to
to distinguish and in reality it's much
bigger for more possibilities than just
these two
you know with more stamps so how can we
resolve the true phase
uh what we can do and what we show here
is
we sample enough of these clones so we
can find clones that are homozygous
at these at this region for these
different haplotypes and we can see
oh here maybe the true phase is actually
acg and cct
and so looking for these ibd or identity
by descent regions
uh we can get the true phase of these
haplotypes
and so that's how we created the i've
created this cassava database so this
phe
is by sampling the ibd regions of the
genome and and using those runs of
homozygosity
that were most likely generated through
you know breeding
or selection and we then also capture if
there are runs of homosexual
relationships
between adjacent haplotypes
um and not only that but one of the
things we have to address is that this
method is going to kind of create a
sparse database because
not every haplotype is being sampled in
every tax set
and so here this is the same picture i
showed before with some missing habitats
one of the things we've done to kind of
make this viable
is by taking the reeds from these
haplotypes we've sampled
we actually realign them to the graph
and find the most likely paths
and and fill in those gaps with most
likely haplotypes from the
types of samples with this realigning of
the whole genome sequence data does is
it fills in the gaps
to kind of fill up the graph to improve
the transitions and the
the model as a whole but doesn't add any
new information or new haplotypes
and so now i'll just show uh we
run an imputation from this uh
phg and same kind of thing with the
other tests but i held out
a test set that were not sampled sampled
their reads to a low coverage
and impute the missing sites and so here
the results from that and um you'll see
it it's
it's not the beagles follows the same
relationship as it did in simulation but
with this phd
it's the same trend but it's translated
lower on the graph and what
uh we're seeing here is that uh we're
not completely able by
this method isn't completely able to
sample all the haplotypes
the diversity happen types either due to
deleterious um alleles
or other population dependent
parameters you know we might not be
exampling all the available haplotypes
um just to interrupt you a second but if
somebody's got a baby can you please
that's my baby that's okay oh sorry
no i'm that's i try to apologize but um
that just makes it adorable carry on
okay
um so we've shown okay
but it does do really well with the low
coverages uh compared to beagle
but how well is good enough so just try
to validate this with some genomic
prediction
how does this imputation accuracy
translate to genomic prediction
so i've just used a subset of clones
from this
hat map did some cross validations with
fresh root yield
and i found that it follows pretty much
the same trend as the amputation
accuracy
as the genomic prediction accuracy um
and that it yeah the highest coverage
beagle is going to do better
because it it can kind of leverage the
information that
the phd can't um
but it is we are you know these are
upwards of
you know near if
if the beagle 5x is the top amount of
genomic prediction accuracy we can get
just with
0.5 x coverage uh the phd can get near
that i would say you know
um and so kind of this brings us the
question is
if it can do pretty well it you know it
does affect it at low coverage
how can we sample more haplotypes
because that seems to be just the last
piece
um to make this an effective tool in a
heterozygous crop like cassava
so here i'm just going to show um some
preliminary data i've got from using
long read technology oxford nanopore
technology
or minion sequencing so here
i've got six clones um
uh that have oxford nanopore data i take
those clones
their wgs data and use um long reads to
phase their data
and i make it i've made a phd database
just with those six lines
uh and then i'm gonna compare it to the
phd i just showed which
is made from the whole hat map too
um so here's what it looks like and
it is lower but it includes data from
far fewer taxa
and so uh i wasn't able to get this huge
bump in accuracy even i didn't show this
but even by combining them i don't get
that bump in accuracy
that i'd like but um this does show a
lot of potential for
maybe if you had a breeding population
if you sequence the parents with
um some long reads and short reads
together and get the face table types
then you can use those
to effectively uh impute in the
offspring or the
in yes so just last i want to summarize
my points is the cassava phd can
leverage ibd haplotypes to get
good imputation accuracy that is
applicable for general prediction
simulation experiments help us validate
and improve our methodology
it shows its real potential if we have
correctly faced apple types
and lastly um you know there is some
potential to use these long-range
technologies
as they get cheaper and more available
to kind of solve the
phasing problem and last i'll just uh
want to acknowledge everyone that's
helped me both uh my mentors kelly and
ed and all the the lab members that have
helped me
uh and especially a big shout out for
peter bradberry
whose uh programming work is you know
mostly support a lot of the results i
have is due to a lot of the work he's
done
and i will take any questions thank you
thank you for your talk evan um so yeah
you can either write
the questions in the chat or you can
also raise your hand if you would like
to
evan i think you need to show us the
baby
you said she was
[Laughter]
[Music]
um if we want to start with liz
do you want to unmute yourself and ask
your question
hi evan
can you hear me okay yes sorry liz i
just uh
didn't see you yeah this is liz so i was
interested in those last results on the
long-range sequencing why you did not
get
better resolution and better accuracy is
that because the method itself is
inherently
error-prone um so it's like i said still
some preliminary data
i think um
so i think what it shows is that we're
able to phase some haplotypes correctly
which
with short reads i've tried phasing with
other methods and it doesn't help
you know trying to giving face apple
types to
uh incorporating face appetite doesn't
help but with the long reads it
it looks like we're getting accurate
haplotypes um
and i think it's probably just a
limitation of only being able to have
those
few only six clones having that data
would probably be the limitation i'd um
and why it wouldn't improve the i i
still need to look into it more
um because i've tried combining both the
ibd haplotypes and those
phase apple types and it hasn't really
improved better than
my big ibd database um
yeah that haplotype imputation can they
can get chimeric
forms of sequencing for the long range
sequencing method so i wondered whether
you were seeing some of that
yeah um i have looked at chimera
you know like creating kind of these
false haplotypes before
and um that may be part of it or maybe
just that we're not it's not
like all the haplotypes that i'm getting
with the
with the long read phasing may be
already captured by all the
ibd apple types right that could be one
thing
um but that is you know that's kind of
my running hypothesis right
now it would i mean i don't have the
data for it really but it would be
interesting if i had
once again if i had offspring i've tried
looking there's not really pedigr
there's not at least whole genome
sequence on the pedigree data i have um
you know if i could look at the direct
offspring of those uh six clones
thanks very nice thank you evan
there was another raised hand by
jean-luc
i don't know um he took his hand back i
don't know what he's done i i loaded it
but
i'm sure um evan so the uh
the simulation what what data did you
actually give the phd in constructing it
did you give it
the fully phased data on the 20 parents
yeah so i phased 20 parents just using
beagle and hap cut and i just gave the
phd and explained or
because that's what i used to simulate
the offspring and so i gave that to the
phd as well
i mean those are no by no means true i
just accept sure
it's true right right right i get it
yeah okay so um
yeah does that answer your question
it does i i guess uh yeah that makes
sense thanks
and they're all iita lines so at least
they're all
somewhat related anyways
you know we never really got a good view
of the baby because
people were talking and then zoom puts
them on the screen or at least i didn't
there were some backlighting issues
thank you so much oh wonderful
very cute um there's one more question
from shitai
in the chat she asks which method
among the two you would recommend for
either irl
or diverse populations um
i think if i had the ability to get long
reads
i would especially if you had
like a finite number of parents you knew
[Music]
okay uh if you had something like you
said if we said something
in maize you know if you had something
like the name
if you get long readings of those
parents and then look have those
faith effects okay well
i better cut off but thank you and thank
you for the questions
thanks for your talk evan um yeah george
will introduce the third and last
speaker for today
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu